fees fines and Petty law enforcement
little Ticky Tac violations can pile up
quickly and are enough to drive even the
most civic-minded citizens crazy radical
thinkers spanning the political Spectrum
from Marx to rothbart have described the
state as a parasite surviving off the
lifeblood of productive taxpaying
citizens but what happens when the
parasite gets too big whether it's a
Once great City on the brink of
bankruptcy a suburb racked with racial
tension between police and the citizens
they're supposed to protect or a town
run by literal Crooks when the Pickin
Get Slim governments tend to find more
creative ways to raise money these are
America's three most fee ridden cities
with the fees that they charge for the
appliance license I mean it's just kind
of ridiculous they just targeting really
the whole city they not doing their jobs
out here Detroit is our number three
most e-d City shortly after declaring
the largest Municipal bankruptcy in in
history Detroit's government started
cooking up all sorts of Revenue
generating schemes such as doubling
expired parking meter finds
unfortunately about half the meters in
Detroit are broken and the city can't
afford to fix them making Detroit one of
the few cities that actually loses money
on parking enforcement they don't fix
the meters but if you park there you get
a ticket but Detroit's most outrageous
scheme is called operation compliance an
initiative to bring all of the city's
small businesses up to code with costly
permitting it kicked off with the stated
goal to shut down 20 non-compliant
businesses a week and I know they need
money but what about the people that's
been here I've been here 15 years should
be cleaning up some of these vacant Lots
out here and cutting some of the grass
throughout the city taking our tax
dollars clean it
up Ferguson Missouri is our number two
most fee ridden city they are riding
tickets so fast in some of these
municipalities now people get get a
ticket one day they don't have a court
date until January when you get pulled
over for like a tail light for example
you
cringe because of the past this city
grabbed headlines after local police
rolled out in full military guard
against protesters in the wake of the
fatal shooting of teenager Michael Brown
but tension between the police and
citizens here runs deep and in no small
part because of a pattern of persistent
Petty law enforcement by the officers
and it's not just Ferguson The
Washington Post uncovered similar law
enforcement in other tiny suburbs just
outside of St Louis going so far as to
call them little foms and if you don't
pay the fines the nightmare is just
beginning they'll give person uh a 4
$500 fine they'll let the attorney know
3 weeks until they can pay the fine and
if they don't pay all of it then they
want to lock them up one local
courthouse issued five arrest warrants
per citizen many of them for delinquent
pay
P Bell California is our number one most
bidden city I'm like a monopoly they
want to take control of the city this is
a bunch of grooks this small California
town just south of Los Angeles rose up
against the local government whose
officials were literally robbing them
and paying themselves some of the most
lucrative government salaries in the
nation they're giving the tickets to
people who Park out there so they can
make Revenue we have very a very
predatory government Bell residents
successfully recalled the entire city
council the mayor and removed city
manager Robert Rizzo who paid himself
$1.5 million a year in salary and
benefits in a community with a per
capita household income of about
$25,000 it's just disgusting what
they're doing with our money it's all
going into their pockets and they don't
care about the community a working-class
community Rizzo and his assistant Angela
Spa are locked up in federal prison but
the residents of bell are still on the
hook for the $1 137 million in debt Left
Behind locals call it the Rizo tax
they're doing the American thing the
government isn't working for them and so
they're taking charge and they're going
to fix it themselves have you seen good
bad or funny government action in your
town we're taking suggestions for our
next episode of America's most and don't
forget to
subscribe and